all right guys
what's up bang bang lunch money time
while wall street's trying to get rich
the rest of us trying to get our lunch
money right i got a hair sticking up on
my head
i got this stupid freaking haircut the
woman made me look i got a blowout going
on
and we're late i'm so sorry i had other
things to do today
it's my fault not hers it is actually my
fault so i apologize in advance
but we have the beautiful intestines
i've been ready with my
hair all in place my hair is not in
place i don't know what's going on up
here i might have to go get a refund for
this stupid
blowout haircut i don't know what a
blowout is i don't but it just looks
like somebody just took a bomb and blew
my hair out in all every direction like
jesus okay okay
don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five block five's got
three products
the first is a us dollar loan against
your crypto collateral the second
is a crypto exchange where you can buy
and sell crypto the third
is a interest bearing account where you
can deposit bitcoin
ether or a stable coin and earn up to
8.6
apy i'm an investor i sit on the board
i'm a happy user basically
anything that blockfi does i'm a fan of
because they're awesome they got great
founders
i was a believer early look at that
okay are you ready
go check out blockfy.com pomp
come on let's go i got things to do i
got a stupid haircut i got to get a
second haircut
all right the first news item
ready you can you can relax though but
that was a lot of energy i wasn't ready
i'm just waiting for the first topics i
can rant the first
topic oracle won the bidding for the u.s
operations for the video sharing app
tick tock beating out microsoft
nobody's commenting it's a high-profile
deal
oracle is set to be announced as tick
tock's trusted tech partner in the us
and the deal is likely not to be
structured as an outright
sale this is complete
garbage balloony they should have shut
this [ __ ] down
imma say it right now the chinese
government said
we're not cool with selling the
algorithm
so they should have shut it down please
don't scream china called the bluff
and the u.s backed down you said
that it was a problem you said it was a
national security concern
you said that they had to sell and then
they said we're not going to sell and
then you caved
this is not what should have happened
has it been reviewed by
the government yet what do you mean like
is this allowed to happen
there's no sale the government can't
stop it they're partners
whatever that means they're specifically
saying they're not selling hold on
the next step is for the white house and
the committee of foreign investment in
the us to approve the deal
adding that the participants believe it
satisfies the concerns around data
security that have been previously
raised by the us government
oh is this are they reviewing it because
it's not an acquisition are they
reviewing it under
the executive order of no transactions
i don't know see this is very confusing
they should not have allowed this to
happen this is nonsense
they're going to be reviewing it at the
syphias committee this week and then be
making a recommendation to the president
so technically it might not go through
my eyeballs can't roll farther in the
back of my head
either make them sell it or kick them
out it's like we walk around
like we got guns and we and we want to
tell everyone like hey we're ready to go
we're ready for a battle and then they
show up and they literally bring a
bazooka we bring a water gun
if you're going to say get out or sell
your assets
if they say we're not selling the assets
you got to make them get out
well that's how this works i don't know
all right next
crazy all right i'm fired up blow out
haircut
we need to we need to flatten that out a
little bit i'm not ready for all this
you see this right here hey you know
what the lady said when she was cutting
my hair
just so we're clear she said be thankful
you have hair
and i said oh lady let me if we go real
deep in there there ain't so much
is losing a lot faster than i want to
admit he has an alter ego when he takes
a shower he looks like completely
different person yeah i'm like man where
did all that go
all right all right you're fine
it's just this little hair like
beautiful inside
it would be fine if i went and i got a
haircut like a week ago and i was like
oh yeah whatever
but like i got the haircut yesterday and
what is this going on all right come on
you slept weird okay new york sports
club owner
town sports international filed for
chapter 11 bankruptcy monday with many
gyms nationwide still
shut by the coronavirus pandemic
gold's gym international sought
protection from its creditors
our 24-hour fitness filed for bankruptcy
in june
people are just buying pelotons left and
right
what do you think
i'm kidding um would you ever go back to
a real gym
like would you go to one of these gyms
that claims that they
are going to be covered sanitized well
no but i'm
a bad person to ask because i've never
gone to a gym i used to go to the group
workout classes
but those aren't happenings not really
but okay i would not right now go sweat
in a room with other
people
but what about outside i can sweat
outside
okay but the virus doesn't exist outside
not where i'm sweating
oh okay no problem okay but is there an
argument it's kind of like when you went
you got your nails done the one time she
was the first person to walk into the
nail salon after they opened up
and she said that it was great don't
listen to his [ __ ] no she said it
was great to be the first one because
when she walked in it was so clean and
sanitized they were taking it so
seriously the day they opened up true
yeah do you think the gyms are doing
that i think i think so and i also think
that like for example if you're on the
treadmill it's a little different than
touching all the weights and stuff but
if it's properly sanitized they say
covet can't live on surfaces
if you sanitize i don't know who knows
oh when i'm on the treadmill i'm
touching lies i'm holding on trying to
not fall off
all right what's next bankrupt
all right anyway we should we should if
we were smart we would create like a
horn and every time somebody goes
bankrupt we'd have to hit the horn
to remind people that
we have to get these people help people
yeah i would open this [ __ ] up
because they feel bad for the gym owners
yeah
okay nvidia nvidia how do you say
in the video um is acquiring chipmaker
arm from softbank for 40 billion
arm will operate as a division of nvidia
and will remain headquartered in the uk
but the deal is still likely to face
intense regulatory
scrutiny the problem is that softbat
softbank bought arm in 2016 for 31
billion
and now it's getting sold for 40.
masasan is striking
he needs cash he's going to get that 40
billion
and he's gonna make a 33 return over
four
years bang bang bang bang bang 10
annualized return
give or take he's gonna have 40 billion
in cash okay and that guy
might get real crazy and he might go
slam it into the public market but
here's what it says softbank paid 32
billion to buy
arm back in 2016 later rolling a 25
stake into the vision fund which is the
vcr
without the earn out the deal is
basically a wash well
so the fact that they put it in vision
fund means that they don't get the value
of off this sale yeah that's not good so
dang so
liquidity moment he needs liquidity yeah
he wants cash
cash is king well i thought you say cash
is not king
cash is trash well i like electronic
cash personally
i'm a big electronic peer-to-peer cash
guy it's called bitcoin
read about it on the internet okay masa
needs money
so he's selling something just like
everyone in march when the liquidity
crisis hit
everyone was selling everything you're
selling your stocks you're selling your
bonds you're selling your kid
well not maybe not your kids but
whatever you could to get cash
you need to stop speaking um next
you know how people all over the country
are now blaming college students for
being like
basically their perpetr perpetua
what's the word perpetuating
perpetuating coveted
and they're just you know throwing these
crazy parties
and they're the reason people are
getting coveted and now mental health
professionals are saying
the media is covering this all wrong
they keep demonizing
demonizing college students maybe you
should stop
because uh it's not good to blame
students for
outbreaks many of them are taking the
virus seriously but there are inevitable
challenges that will arise from bringing
hundreds if not
thousands of young people back to campus
it's just not great
to blame the kids for your problems
for our problems for society's bra
oh my god today's lunch money is trash
what go on oh i can speak now all right
do you see how many times you can't
pronounce words when i'm not talking
this show it would be a disaster if it
was just you you have 30 seconds
i get back all my time it's like in
congress when they have a hearing
i give back my time i don't need anymore
but with this suspect
what do you think about the college
students being blamed for this pandemic
people are dumb they're just looking for
somebody to blame they want to blame
young people you know people want to
party
get out of their way ain't going to kill
them they don't care no
they do care because no they don't well
they should care but we shouldn't no
they shouldn't we should they're not at
risk
there's been plenty of people who are
young with uh
conditions how many people have died
from pneumonia
i'm not talking about everyone i'm
talking about specifically college kids
kids who are 18 to 22 year olds that
aren't i don't
have to look up the things that don't
have pre-existing conditions okay they
shouldn't
they shouldn't worry about the virus
okay but they're not only
interacting with each other they're also
interacting with other people
true true but i'm just saying you're
wondering why they're doing it and i'm
saying
they want a party and they don't care
about about getting sick that's not what
i'm saying what i'm saying is when
you're trying when you're a nation
trying to contain a virus
everybody should be doing their part but
sweden didn't lock down and sweden
looks pretty pretty good facts y'all
want the facts
you're gonna come here and i'm gonna
give you the facts go check out sweden
no lockdown nope they didn't lock down
why did that work
i don't know by the way i'm not a
scientist i don't know i literally don't
know what's going on
i don't know if are people dying are
they not dying are the numbers real are
they not real
is the virus ravaging society
or are literally people just
politicizing everything i
literally do not know what's going on
anymore it's insane
i don't know what's going on there's
people with mass there's people without
mass there's people who are partnering
there's people who aren't
there's literally cities where they're
just like ah go do whatever you want go
in the bar go eat lunch whatever
there's places where like you can't
leave your home or you'll get arrested
i don't know i literally at this point
i'm just saying i don't know anymore
okay beyond meat is launching meat-free
meatballs in grocery stores chicken
balls strike again
do you remember guys when at the
beginning of the pandemic i was really
upset because i went to get
beef for the meatballs but then there
was no beef there was a beef shorter so
i ended up getting
chicken so i got made chicken balls um
chicken meatballs no wait chicken balls
whatever uh
beyond meat which is the meatless
meatball
uh is launching in grocery stores
nationwide
should we go try them we should do a
cooking show one day a cooking edition
and we should literally make the
meatless meatballs and then taste them
live on the show
well the company first made meatballs to
a partnership with subway last year
but grocery stores have also been asking
for the item
demand for refrigerated plant-based
meatballs has surged 145
in the 52 weeks ending and august 9th
yeah i've had it before it's good i mean
i it's not bad
i love real meat but it's pretty close
it's not bad i don't know if i'd say
good but it's not bad okay
okay what's next um oh so apparently
musk shared his thoughts on bill gates
um there was a tweet what did he say
someone said
good day what's your opinion about bill
gates's declarations referring to
electric
trucks regards and elon musk said
he has no clue so basically
billionaire versus billionaire throwdown
edition
quietly i would just like to point out
that's
not quiet this is my quiet voice if you
want me to get like
no i would just like to point out that
uh
classic example this is only news
because people ascribe
uh competence in one area to every area
just because bill gates is rich
does not mean that he knows anything
about electricity so uh
so basically gates in a blog post
explained why he was dubious about the
potential for electric vehicles as long
haul vehicles
his reasons batteries are big and heavy
he said
even with big breakthroughs in battery
technology electric vehicles will
probably never be a practical solution
for things like 18 wheel wheelers cargo
ships and passenger
jets electricity works when you need to
cover short distances
but we need a different solution for
heavy long-haul
vehicles and musk disagrees because this
is musk's entire
life this is his business this is his
life's calling
yeah okay so hold on a second maybe bill
gates is talking about
jets but around trucks specifically
you do realize that a truck engine is
heavier
than a battery no i'm not excited
you didn't well how i mean compared to
what kind of battery
an electric battery to power a truck
that's the whole i don't know how heavy
it is okay guys
well i don't know i'm not a scientist i
think i might just start saying to all
kinds of these things
i don't know i literally don't know
anymore i don't know what's real i don't
know what's not
but i'm gonna go with a miss billionaire
bashing
session i'm going to go with mr elon
musk as uh having more
knowledge of how electric vehicles runs
than bill gates bill
love you send me some money but no
are you ready for my joke today sure i
try
wait okay
i thought you were going to interrupt me
again i tried to pre-empt you
i drank i tried fishing with eminem
today
it didn't go too well as he kept
dropping
the bass
because not only his bass or like bass
like the fish
too funny today my son asked me if i'd
seen the new movie
the truck i answered no but i saw the
trailer yesterday
guys this is getting cringe literally
from now on i want to train everyone i
want to see in the youtube analytics
when we get to the point where she says
time for a joke
just drop off no just like and just see
ya
people like them do they yep all right
that was good
okay guys that's it for lunch monday
today well while she's trying to get
rich russell she's trying to get our
lunch money
right i apologize i was late blow out
haircut
things to do this morning but patient
polina
waited all day goodbye see you guys
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends